you found the house of your dreams and
you have to take on a mortgage to pay
for it from now on you'll be better
informed and safeguarded in the european
union
home buyers will be given better
information credit institutions will
send out a document presented in a
consistent format which will enable
buyers to more accurately compare the
costs and financial consequences of
taking out the loan gone are the days of
easy credit mortgage sellers will be
obliged to carry out better screening
before giving out loans however there
will be no obligation for home buyers to
make any payments to take one out
of
home buyers in europe will also benefit
from a cooling off period of seven days
before signing for a mortgage or a right
of withdrawal for up to seven days
afterwards depending on the country the
final report also still offers or of the
possibility for a consumer once an offer
has been made by a bank or a credit
institution to think this over talked
with his family with his friends maybe
advise us and to make sure that he makes
a good decision to protect buyers in
case of crisis or default returning the
property would suffice to repay the loan
as long as the lender and borrower
expressly agree to this beforehand
members of the european parliament
approve these measures in a vote in
plenary but postpone the final vote on
the legislation until they receive the
guarantee that they'll be properly
implemented by the member states